Speaker 1: I want to play a few clips for
you today of a monstrous Donald Trump being
interviewed by the Christian Broadcasting Network
and declaring himself a Christian savior. This is
really a wild God complex that Donald Trump has.
It's like a Jesus complex, I guess you would say.
Let's start with this first clip where Trump
claims no one ever has done more for Christianity
and for all religions than Trump himself.
Speaker 3: You know, nobody has done more for
Christianity. Nobody has done more
for religion of all type than me.
And they're really doing things now, too.
And I've always said it. They are against
organized religion. They're against Christianity.
Speaker 1: And of course. No, we're not. What we
are against is civil law based on Christian
doctrine. We're against and meshing church
and state. We're against discrimination against
non-Christians or simply nonbelievers. Remember,
non religion is protected and the absence of
religion is equally protected. But Trump with
a real God complex. Now I do want to say. I don't
think Trump is the person who's done the most for
Christianity and all religions as he claims. But.
If indeed the leaked Supreme Court decision holds
and I believe it will, we know it's an accurate
draft, but it's a draft from February. If it holds
in a few weeks when it's released and Roe v
Wade is overturned. Trump will be responsible
for one of the major accomplishments, I would
call it a major coup. But that term now we've
got to be careful with that term. We want to be
clear about what we mean. It would be one of the
major accomplishments of the retrograde religious
conservative movement overturning Roe v Wade after
for four decades. Really pieces of five decades,
actually. Actually, no, it's just five decades.
I don't even have to hedge would be an absolute
major accomplishment. And Trump is responsible
for that. He's the guy who appointed the justices
that made it possible. Let's go to the next clip.
Here is Donald Trump sort of now on the on
the heels of what was it, JP? JD Mendel. No,
JD Vance winning his primary on Tuesday night and
J.R. Maju winning his primary on Tuesday night.
Trump feels emboldened about the power of his
endorsement, and he's telling everybody else,
I don't endorse you. It's very bad.
Speaker 3: I remember Joe Biden saying
months ago at this press conference he had that
egos. He couldn't believe all these Republicans
still afraid of Trump is like, oh, you're afraid
of Trump. Should Republicans be afraid of you,
the ones that are not in line with you and your
views? Well, if they want to win politically,
probably because of I endorsed him, they went.
And if I don't endorse him, then I'll win. I mean,
that's almost 100% of the case now.
Speaker 1: It's really more like 57%
of the case. And I think it's really important
to remember that although Trump did get two
victories so far this primary season and he may
get more. There's no question Trump may get more.
Trump's record on endorsements is pretty,
pretty shoddy. It's kind of like Swiss cheese.
First of all, he endorsed a lot of presumptive
frontrunners and incumbents. And there's a
major incumbency bias in American politics.
And even given all that, his record is not
that great, like it's hovering right around and
slightly below 60%. So it's not actually true
that everybody Trump touches turns to
gold, but it may end up being true in 2022
remains to be seen. One last clip here.
Here's Trump talking about Disney. Of course,
Disney now under fire for opposing Florida's don't
say gay bill. And people are protesting at Disney
and they want to cancel Mickey and Minnie and all
these different things. Anyway, Trump says Walt
Disney wouldn't be happy with what's going on.
Speaker 3: I think what's happened with Disney and
what Disney is doing, the Walt Disney is looking
down. What's he think? He's not happy. Okay. Well,
he said, whatever happened to my beautiful magic
kingdom? He's not happy. No, it's it's a terrible.
Speaker 1: So anyway, there's Trump speculating
on how Walt Disney would feel about the Magic
Kingdom today based on Disney's opposition to the
don't say gay bill. They don't say gay bill is,
of course, disgusting, and I hate theme parks and
have no interest in ever going to Disney again.
But I like Disney's taking a position on this.
And by the way, Disney wouldn't take a position on
this. I don't think if they didn't calculate that,
it's probably an okay PR move to take the position
that they did opposing the don't say gay bill.
A very strange interview with Donald Trump, but
an emboldened Donald Trump on the heels of some
primary endorsements, successes. We'll have these
video clips for you if you're just listening to
the podcast today or maybe listening on the radio.
We'll have these video clips on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.